Remember the context of Putin's announcement.
He wants to ease the Western sanctions on
Russia, and he wants to do it by portraying
Russia, portraying himself as not just the
king-maker in the Middle East, but also a
peacemaker.
This announcement was made in advance of the
so-called peace talks in Geneva, and Putin
wanted to impress the West, primarily the
White House by his efforts to withdraw the
troops or lower, let's not say withdraw, lower
the number of troops and jets and so on, in
order to promote peace.
Given the economic situation in Russia, foreign
policy is something that greatly strengthens
devotion to Putin, which in turn is the cornerstone
of regime's legitimacy.
Putin needs a lot of victories in foreign
policy, and he can get far more victories
still in Syria.
So what do you think of Putin’s permanent
strategy?
Please let us know in the comment section,
and please let us know if there’s anything
else you want us to cover in 60 seconds.